um chicote bull as meninas bom que bush
bom o que ó no meu peito bate um coração
nordestino molecada nós se tivermos um
degrau dessa nesse site e caiu
e aí esse jornal tudo vocês é continuar
essa postagem no facebook já me ajuda
muito
clique em compartilhar você me ajuda
muito a divulgação viu gente agora de 13
de julho de 2013
é lógico que a gente vai fazer um super
encontro em fortaleza e também foi
fortaleza lei que a descrição do vídeo
que tem que ser o local a data ea hora
que é pra você e pra ele ir lá tirar
umas fotos base o que é isso aí vamos ao
vivo vamos ao vivo vamos ao filho
vamos ao vivo então muita gente sabe eu
fui o programa esquenta de regina casé
aí eu tive que me deslocado que ele o
piauí para rio de janeiro e pará
interesse na província de janeiro teve
que haviam que eu nunca nunca nunca
tinha andado de avião na minha vida as
horas do ps no pobre lá no piauí
nunca tinha andado de avião não é assim
primeiro que as viagens que eu fazia era
aqui pra perto de bisar de avião e
segundo que eu sou pobre tinha dois
motivos fortes para lutar na guerra
ganhou o primeiro normal todo mundo que
eu sou pobre segunda eu tenho medo do
canal de avião na época de normal jogar
no meio normal assim a meninada fim o
tempo
pega traindo a onde você tem verdade eu
descobri na linha
fui eu ae
porque tenho o melhor avião porque pra
mim transporte é no chão que o cara de
onde estavam cair na parcial que lá sei
que vamos por hora
pavan bateu a meu pé quem propalar
samuel
no mês a votar nele e avião seja saber
se um problema você está o senhor graças
a deus nada de errado chapo só nenhum
mel sobra nem sei quem é atribuída a
pessoa só não caiu mais úmidas o avião
de transporte mais seguro do mundo é um
sei lá uma em cada cem mil aviões
ficarem sim ela que se eu tiver dentro
da f-1 dos 100 mil que vai cair ou não
não é enterrado por trem por tudo isso
estão na terra é uma coisa que se tornou
então vamos com o vôo foi na melhor
forma
nunca tirei do aeroporto no catete e
toda vez que tinha perdido o voo tk
alegra hoje eu não morro e aí fui para o
porto é tal cheguei lá fischer quintal
das moças bonitas lá fazendo costa teve
paulo prática que essa moça aprender que
a proporção bonito né parece que nasceu
photoshop na cara a envelhecer tem lá
conversei um pouquinho salata poderá
descontar e ficar pensando na mota aí
fui pavihão eu acho engraçado avião é
que quando a etapa por fora mas um
gigante com um cinto de paixão aqui que
nezinho sabiá é de levar mais a isso eu
escuto ao se mexer tava pão
pra mim já estava até ram só que a hora
que ele faz uma curva de festa ocorra
mas não acha que o sector e achou ficam
fininhas sabe essa é a vontade de voar
em uma coisa foi acordar gente parece
querer uma vida é como se o corpo do
cafezinho assim é daqui não tem volta 4
rui provou ano que enquanto vando ficou
parado e quanto àqueles para joãozinho
aquela coisinha pequena eu não confio
nas o homem fazendo com fio
imagina se foi um estagiário que fez
nada de boi marinho tratava de burra'
uma ala do dia está já leva a dor por
nós eu falei ficar cola a [ __ ] da ásia
é e solda não é concurso e não haviam
saído de bock que boa e boa parece que
andamos a sal no outro gol e quanto
ainda nuno ficou um treino difícil do
meu desejo ao diabo a cabeça toda é que
o sim mas falei por atacado que seu país
quer sediar a copa eo que é que eu sou
uma pessoa muito impressionada consulta
tipo de rosto da menina eu já imaginava
em campo com ela depois o psd
a rampa na casa casa bonita a caixa
econômica ligada do espírito lá acho
total do rio pan assim o seu avião não é
que entra a viajar junto do ensaio no
campo caiu no mapa acham do dos pés de
um braço tem campo chorando para o meio
como esquecer
aí o avião estava voando é beleza ou
citá-la aceitar certas pessoas com cara
de normal a via marginal da avenida
nossa senhora copacabana fechou todo
mundo quer então que está tudo bem né aí
a aeromoça vai moça bonita lá leçon tão
bonita se acha o moço se acha a
verdadeira você acha qo da xuxa encerado
acho shell co tão bonita assim ela só
quer ser chefe não passa de criticar
fizeram gol só que a bola não passa de
dólar o que eu mais gosto e aeromoça é a
mãe dela eu não sei que já começou era
moça mas parece que elas conversa
ovulando telhada falou se deseja
concorrer
assim o dia que eu tenho no bolso deve
dar para comprar comida de sanduíche
feras perceber a falta o pão um presunto
dele frio só com a transição do egipto
onde estava em cima do brasil
gente pra te isso quer dizer que só que
é anual e sem buscar o pão lá há 20 mil
pés de altura multiplique o preço só
pode ser só porque está no ar
achando concluir o pedido 5 não era só
que eu sei que o avião e tratar no alto
é bem bem lá total só pelo imaginar o
que era pão alto porque tem uma praga
está saindo aí a alta ligado se paga é
um pouco o senhor tá mais alto ainda
passar um pouco seu estar muito alto
então vai falar que era moça tirar umas
férias
na vida tirar foto dele e acho que o é
meu livro de saviano balançar eu trancar
um passado nem no tuf acaba de colocar
um passa no pensamento doente e foi
assim que eu fui primeira vez até gostei
falar e até um pouco frustrado porque eu
pensava lá em cima no céu e ver jesus
logo a hebe se podia ouvir ninguém
estava em um motel botão branco assim
então é isso aí muito obrigado por ter
se tivesse vindo até aqui e agradecer a
toda essa galera que me manda presente
manda carta que que gostei que continuo
facebook eu coloco vídeo e agradeceu eu
cheguei pintado
olha a música les aluno ir todos aqui é
um presente da adriana beatriz lá e em
recife pernambuco adriana muito obrigado
pelo presente muito obrigado eu vou usar
sim muito essa luta aqui muito obrigado
por fumar renan e adriano disse que a
avianca ea equipe mandante teve pejo
encontram e se eu venho também uma outra
blusa e esse sim muito fofo foi alheia
andrade que me mandou ela joão pessoa e
é muito obrigado pelos presentes
eu ia lá uma palestra que eu tenho
pessoas num carro ligeiro gabriel porto
velho com um monte de gente lá mas eu
quero que você começa aqui em baixo uma
coisa que você nunca tinha feito e
quando você fez não se achou muito legal
para tal tem 60 mil inscritos obrigado a
chegar a essa marca é muito obrigado a
todos vocês que fiquem gostei
obrigado a todos vocês que ficam em
curtir quando eu posso emitir facebook é
isso aí você gostou desse vídeo clique
aqui e gostei sim clique inscrever a
equipa toda vez que tiver um vídeo novo
você sabe eu não tenho de novo segue no
twitter acima no facebook e seguem está
grande disse que tudo é para curtir um
vídeo novo coloco nesses treinos vão
saber que vai ter gente não sabe então
segue assim muito mais avançado legal
aqui pra você que não destino a retalho
e gosta do nordeste tá nesse site aí na
descrição do vídeo é só você ir lá fazer
o seu pedido e tirou foto manda pra mim
no facebook viu muito obrigado e falou